Fortunately, there's a better way. We can make in, make use of
an already defined mathematical construct called a permutation, that is,
we can describe the same elements as in English by the following. X has the same
elements as Y if the elements of X are a permutation of the elements of Y. Or,
the other way around. The elements of Y are permutations of the elements of X.
Because we know that permutation is well-defined, has well-defined mathematical
properties, we don't have to write it out for ourselves. We could just rely on
an already existing well-defined concept. Nevertheless, for
the, for the purposes of this exercise, let's, let's build up a a specification
of what it, what it means for one vector to be a permutation of another vector.